hey Doug Walker here if you look online
right now you see everybody's talking
about net neutrality there's a good
reason we've been putting off this video
for a bit to find the best time to get
the best bump that can be the most
useful now it's the time on December
14th to vote for the Internet as we know
it will be held and the FCC under as you
PI has shown to be one that doesn't care
what the consumer or the public thinks
mr. pie has refused to cooperate with
the New York Attorney General regarding
all the oddities surrounding the
previous public comment period mr. pie
has called net neutrality supporters
desperate he also just had a closed-door
meeting with Verizon in DC he's even
refused to delay the vote even though
there's a very important case going on
in the US Court of Appeals Ninth Circuit
that case being the FTC versus AT&T
Mobility pretty much any company as long
as they buy or set up a phone or
internet service provider can avoid
protection actions from the FTC and in
this case if that ruling is not repealed
the FCC will ship responsibility for
handling net neutrality complaints to
the FTC
what that means is they will have
limited options for fighting for you
then this makes it much easier for
people and sites to be abused by big
corporations I know what you're thinking
oh come on that won't happen
it already has Comcast AT&T Verizon
Sprint and many others have tried to
manipulate the system but were stopped
if net neutrality is gutted they won't
be able to stop them now these examples
are usually done for one of two reasons
one they want you to pay more or two
they want you to use a crappy service
they just invented over the much better
one that you're currently using everyone
can see them doing this and they think
we're not gonna do anything about it
that we're just gonna pay for it this
may even interfere with state rights as
the FCC wants to block individual states
from making their own net neutrality
rules this will most likely result in
what Poarch ago is going through now a
country with no net neutrality that
means saying hello to additional tiers
and fees use Facebook YouTube Gmail
Spotify guess what you're in for
additional tiers now so what can we do
we can make some noise now with the FCC
but with your local and federal
representatives there's just two things
you need to do go to battle for the
Netcom and call your members of the
House and Senate and then go to your
state's website and find your local
representative and call them and just
tell them you want
net neutrality passed in your state it's
that simple but we all got to do it
however if you like to do more you can
donate to the e F F or the ACLU trust me
they'll be fighting for all of us in the
future
links to everything I was talking about
as well as other videos discussing net
neutrality and ways to give to the e FF
and the ACLU are all below thank you for
watching and be sure to share this with
your friends and family they're trying
to make us lose this battle but we can
still win the war they say freedom isn't
free you always gotta fight for it well
the government is trying to make us pay
for it I'd rather fight first join the
fight and spread the word thank you so
much for listening
you